foreign
grew up in Santa Rosa California
and her best friend was a woman named
Joy Durand who lived on the northeast
outskirts of town
at midnight on the evening of October 8
2017 Joy's telephone rang
the voice said simply you must evacuate
now
you don't have time to pack
fire is coming
Joy gathered her parents and her
six-year-old son and they hurried
outside the Wildfire which at that point
was just over the ridge from Joy's house
sounded like a jet engine going at Full
Throttle
the family got in their car drove away
and within minutes their home had burned
To The Ground incinerated by the
blowtorch flames of the tubs fire
all night long my wife got texts and
messages from friends and family and
while we didn't know the whole situation
it was clear that a disaster was
unfolding in her hometown
no one thought that fire could penetrate
so deeply into the city
but on that evening 22 people lost their
lives and over 5 000 homes and
structures were destroyed
Wildfire is a large and growing
challenge to the west and to the world
what happened in Santa Rosa is becoming
all too common Paradise in 2018
Australia in 2020 Europe in 2022 and
fire experts say that we should get
ready for more Santa roses because it's
likely to get worse before it gets
better
now
beyond the major costs in lives and
property and the economy there's also a
big carbon impact to Wildfire in fact
the additional carbon from California's
2020 wildfires was greater than the
carbon that Californians had worked so
hard to save over the previous two
decades
the largest fires are called mega fires
these are the ones that burn over a
hundred thousand acres with the
intensity that can threaten aquifers and
biodiversity and even cause Forest
conversion in which trees are so damaged
that they just don't grow back these
fires are getting worse as well in fact
eight of the ten largest megafires in
California history have happened over
just the last five years
many people feel overwhelmed by this
situation I know I did
so two years ago working with great
people
I closed a chapter of my life in
Aerospace and I started a new journey to
see if I could understand the Wildfire
crisis better and what could be done
about it
I started working with leaders from
firefighting and philanthropy
entrepreneurship science tribal
communities and together we co-founded
an organization called mega fire action
whose sole purpose is to solve the mega
fire crisis and I've come to believe
that if we take a holistic approach we
have an opportunity to establish a new
relationship with fire to work safely
with fire and potentially to solve this
wicked problem
the path forward has three solutions
the first is fire adapted communities
the second is resilient Landscapes and
the third is innovative fire management
so for the first fire adapted
communities what we need to do is to
clear the brush and the vegetation from
uh homes from the immediate proximity of
homes next we need to use fire resistant
materials in the homes and the roofs and
then the third thing is to where
possible protect against
Embers flying Embers by protecting the
home from openings like your air vents
and your chimneys
now communities have a strong shared
interest to perform this work along the
exterior boundary of the community
because it reduces the chance that fire
will penetrate deeply into the city as
it did in Santa Rosa
the second solution is resilient
Landscapes and if you take one lesson
from this talk it's this in order to
solve the mega fire crisis we need to
bring our Western Landscapes back into a
healthy balance by reducing the
overgrown brush and trees in the
wildlands and the forest here we're
finally starting to take to heart the
wisdom of the indigenous peoples of the
Americas who knew that fire was a
natural part of the landscape and who
introduced low intensity fire good fire
on a regular basis at the right times
when this is done well as around the
communities of South Lake Tahoe then it
can actually divert a mega fire as bad
as the one that they experienced in uh
2021 it can also potentially prevent a
mega fire from occurring which is what
some people think happened in Napa of
last year
but the scale of this challenge is huge
there are hundreds of millions of Acres
of Wildland in the American forests the
forest service hopes to reduce the risk
on 50 million high priority Acres over
the next 10 years but the challenge is
that they're only accomplishing a few
million Acres a year and so we're not at
the pace or scale that we need to do to
address this challenge
so what do we need to do
well the first thing that we need to do
is to
essentially hire train and retain many
more workers who will be doing the hard
work of defusing the time bombs inside
our Western forests we need to pay them
well we need to support them with
full-time work and we need to protect
them from liability where necessary the
next thing we need to do is to empower
them with Innovation and right now there
are an incredible number of great
companies and organizations that are
working to bring this Innovation to
reality
just one of these companies is called
burnbot and what they're hoping to do is
to make controlled Burns safer and
faster they're going to establish a
burned perimeter around an area with a
remotely piloted Rover and then they can
bring a drone into the middle of it drop
some fire into it and burn that interior
area safely it's a brilliant but a
simple idea and I think we're going to
need a lot more of this kind of
innovation if we're going to scale up to
the to the size of the problem that we
have before us
now the first two solutions that I've
talked to you about are pretty well
agreed the third one Innovative fire
management is somewhat more
controversial
but I think it offers huge potential to
address and solve the Wildfire problem
what we need is innovation and
technology that can rapidly detect and
assess fire and then quickly put it out
when it gets bad
and here speed is Paramount because when
you're in the worst kind of fire days
these are the hottest driest and
windiest fire days if you can't bring
fire management resources to a fire very
quickly then it is likely that you won't
be able to contain that fire
here we need to look at the example of
the quick reaction force of Southern
California
which is really designed in some ways
for these toughest days
the qrf is a public-private partnership
which now has three Chinook helicopters
these are the big ones with the two
rotors on the top and each of them can
drop up to 3 000 gallons of water on a
fire day or night and they can do it
very precisely they can also refill up
to six times an hour so they can bring a
lot of Mass to the problem
over the course of two years of
demonstrations the qrf has demonstrated
that this model has great potential that
in fact if you can bring a lot of fire
management resource to a fire very
quickly you can get on top of fires
before they get big and unmanageable and
this opens up an exciting potential
future
imagine
this model with a series of larger drone
Vehicles distributed across the
landscape in higher uh fire risk areas
imagine these vehicles positioned
periodically along utility lines or in
areas of of higher fire risk deep in the
forest
this is such a distributed network if
connected to the right sensor system
could offer a future in which we are
able to really put out fires on the
worst fire days and even in remote
communities uh companies like rain and
Joby Aviation are working on this Vision
today
the sensor system will also be very
important for the resolution of this
problem
the system which will entail both
ground-based aerial and space-based
platforms won't be important just
because we're going to be able to see
and detect fire where and when it pops
up but also because it'll enable us to
differentiate between good and bad fire
low intensity fire and high intensity
fire which is very important because we
need more lower intensity fire on the
landscape to rejuvenate our forests
just as much as we need to know where
and when fire risks becoming higher
intensity
fire is a prism through which we can see
the future of Humanity's relationship
with natural systems working together
and supported by technology we can build
a world in which communities are
resilient to Wildfire and in which
forests are brought back into a healthy
balance ultimately we can build a future
in which we don't just manage fire to
protect human life and property but also
to protect the biosphere for Global
carbon emissions and for biodiversity
ultimately we need to become the crew of
spaceship earth so let's get to work
let's learn from fire and let's build a
resilient sustainable future thank you